nick is with us in Mississippi hi Nick
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey
thank you for taking the call
sure what's up so I'm a little bit of
trouble I just started listening to you
probably about a week ago and I'm
stacking dead okay how much that you got
so right now I'm living with my
girlfriend and we have a combined total
of about forty seven eight hundred
dollars we we don't have a combined
total because we aren't married so how
much debt do you have okay just me we're
going to be looking at probably about
probably about 25 26 okay and how much
do you owe on your car
$18,000 less on the car the monthly
payment at 385 gotcha okay and how much
do you own student loans seven right now
is about six but as soon as I go this
next semester it's gonna go up another
six and a half okay what are you
studying I'm going for software
development okay and in a four-year
degree or two um I had a little bit of
schooling before I went I did have to
cut down the credits a little bit due to
my full-time job are you trying to get a
four-year degree yes it's gonna be four
year okay how much how much longer
before you complete it I'm looking at
about two and a half three years okay
and are you working full-time now yes I
am I'm not a salary job and how much do
you make forty thousand before bonuses
okay doing what I made a general manager
at a Pizza Hut good for you okay and
what are your bonuses you look like um
it really depends on sales and off
coming revenue what do you expect to
make not counting the 40 anywhere
between two to four hundred extra a
month okay so another four thousand
bucks give or take
okay and so you know good year you're
gonna make forty forty forty four forty
$5,000 on it and you have an $18,000 car
and you have $6,000 of student loans and
you are not cashflow in college I am NOT
I am paying a little bit for it because
my student loans won't pay for all of it
so there's about $400 a month going into
school okay so what are you paying for
school school right now is looking at
411 credit hour nine credit hours a term
there's four times a year with the
school that I'm going through
okay so 3,600 4000 bucks that's only
four thousand bucks that I did that
wrong mr. Knight
it would be four thousand dollars in
terms yeah and they're giving me one
thousand dollar scholarship for two
years sir makes three thousand one
thousand per term scholarship makes a
three thousand per term okay right right
which every term is about three months
gotcha
okay all right so and you're how old I
am twenty currently okay all right so
here's the way I answer questions you
said you just discovered us and I've
been broke in a you know as a
millionaire and I lost everything and I
started over and I've counseled people
for thirty years
okay um okay the shortest method to
financial peace to having some wealth
and to not being broke and stressed okay
number one you have a roommate you do
not have a wife so you do not pay her
bills you do not pay her debts and she
does not pay your debts okay all right
just pretend from a business and a legal
perspective what you have is a roommate
that's how the law looks at it and so if
you paid $10,000 her student loan though
and she decided run off with your best
friend she just took your money okay
right if you if it was your wife it'd be
a completely different scenario legally
and so forth okay so you don't pay each
other's bills on your roommates number
one number two you have a car you cannot
in this situation an $18,000 car when
you make 40 is financial suicide and
it's what's holding you back
number three you should be cash flowing
college and I think you can if you get
on a very tight budget and don't spend
money on anything except survival and
college right and that's where I would I
would have you to do that is your
shortest path to wealth
it's your shortest path to completing
your degree your shortest path to
becoming a software developer your
shortest path to making $150,000 a year
doing that and doing and living your
dream as fast as you possibly can
rather than wallowing in car debt
wallowing in student loan debt to where
the 32 year old version of you hates the
20 year old version of you right that's
where you're headed right now because
you bought your doing a bunch of crap
that you know you're paying for stuff
left and right okay so you're not doing
anything evil as a matter of fact I
think for a 20 year old I think you're
doing you know you you've them it's
amazing what you've accomplished I'm
proud of you but I bet you are you are
you're heading down the interstate the
wrong way with your foot on the gas so
I'm saying hey get off the exit turn
around you're going the wrong direction
and some pretty severe things I'm
suggesting okay
number one your social life is just
going to disappear because you're gonna
be on a written budget that involves
eating and school right you're gonna be
no fun for a while but guess what it
ain't no fun having a hundred thousand
dollars of student loan debt either
ain't that the truth so you know and
you're gonna be driving a car that is
not got the sex appeal the one you've
got to drive god you're gonna be driving
a hoopty that you can pay cash for and
just like you're a college kid or
something because you are so little you
live like a broke college kid paid cash
for college get out of school as fast as
you can the last thing I tell you is as
you start to get into your software
development training have you actually
taking any of those classes yet I've
done a little fiddling on my own
as far as programming goes but I am
still about a year out before they start
teaching actual software development
sighs oh yeah if you can as soon as you
actually get some level of skills you
probably can make what you're making now
at an entry-level position with a tech
company our company that has a tech
department like we do okay okay my
entry-level guys in tech make more than
you make on my team Wow okay and so you
could do that while you're finishing
school and maybe be sitting right where
you end up working but at a minimum be
getting some real on-the-job experience
and be getting paid more which helps you
get through school and by the way a
company that's supporting a technology
department that size might pay for your
tuition if you could make the jump over
so as soon as you can get where you have
a tech have some value to offer someone
that has a tech department start looking
at making the move that direction they
might pick up your tuition and at a
minimum I think you can make more as you
as you you know you don't have any value
to add right now cuz you'll know
anything yet you're just fiddling right
but as soon as you get there I think
that that I think you're there and it
might only be 12 months away and so and
you know your side hustle right now
could be all kinds of stuff around that
fiddling you know you might make an
extra thousand bucks a month fiddling if
you watch what you're doing right mm-hmm
and you know just learning and pushing
in doing all this kind of stuff and
anything you can make like that's going
to clean up some of these messes and so
goal number one is add no more debt goal
number two is begin to reduce debt by
getting rid of the car okay now with the
car it's probably valued at you know
about sixteen seventeen so there still
would be a little bit of the car payment
you got Laura you got to borrow the
difference Yeah right but at least you
won't have $18,000 hanging over your
head while you're making forty and
trying to go to school right those
ratios just don't work mathematically
cuz you're just you're carrying a heavy
weight you got a lot going on here
including the fact that we haven't even
entered the whole relationship zone of
what's going on with your
in room 8 there I mean that you got a
lot of stuff going on here and so decide
what you want to win at and focus on
that Hey good to talk to you sir I'm
honored to speak with you I think you're
sharp young guy